sciences bonjour et bienvenue dans le
bêtisier de stop science un bêtisier un
peu spécial quand même puisque nous
allons parler des ratés de l'évolution
les reportages animaliers et les
documentaire nous montre la nature sous
son plus beau jour
nous démontrons à quel point les pelles
et majestueuse et comment les êtres
vivants s'entredévorent joyeusement pour
que règne un équilibre où chaque chose
est à sa place
ravi il nous montre comment la nature
avec un grand n ai bien fait bien fait
vous avez dit bien
et non la nature n'est pas fait pour que
nous la trouvions belle et les êtres
vivants se fiche pas mal que nous les
trouvions beau ou non chaque vie humaine
son existence pour elle même et les
espèces évoluent sans but précis si ce
n'est de continuer à exister et que le
résultat soit agréable ou non de notre
point de vue n'a pas d'importance
sinon comment expliquer l'existence des
parasites des bactéries et autres
moustiques type amedi à pourrissent
l'existence à base utiles mahut
si le monde avait été parfaitement conçu
chaque chose y compris chaque espèce
aurait sa place et la nature n'aurait
pas besoin de se reprendre à deux fois
oui mais voilà comme les espèces
évoluent sans se soucier des autres
elle se fiche pas mal de faire dans le
déjà-vu on appelle cela une convergence
pour sa venue dans cette cérémonie de
remise du prix de la meilleure
convergence et les nominés pour la plus
belle convergence sont les dauphins
ichtyosaures et requins tous adaptés de
façon indépendante à la vie aquatique
les ptérosaures les chauves souris et
les oiseaux tous adaptés au vol battu de
façon indépendante aussi mais les
tenants du vol plané ne sont pas loin
avec les serpents et les lézards les
grenouilles les écureuils et plus
inattendu les calamars et les poissons
enfin dans la catégorie chars d'assaut
vivants sont nommés les tortues les en
kilos d'or et les tatous on les
applaudit bien fort donc la concurrence
entre les espèces aboutit souvent à des
convergences
c'est à se demander si la nature est
vraiment bien fait il n'y a qu'à
demander aux concombres de mer non
content de ne pouvoir se mouvoir comme
un animal devrait pouvoir le faire
le pauvre concombres de mer certes aussi
de squat à tout un tas de petites
bestioles parasites et son anus sert
même de planck pour un poisson ou si
elle doit faire mal décidément je ne
sais pas si la nature est bien faite
mais en tout cas il ne manque pas
d'humour et la plupart des espèces
souffre même d'imperfections c'est à
dire des caractères qui ne sont pas tout
à fait aussi bien adapté qu'il le
devrait à leur environnement atteindre
pas adapté ce n'est donc pas le rôle de
la sélection naturelle de fer
s'améliorer les espèces oui certes mais
seulement si on part du principe que jeu
de la sélection naturelle
c'est seulement les meilleurs qui
gagnent mais pour gagner au jeu de la
sélection naturelle
il suffit de parvenir à transmettre ces
jeunes en faisant plein d'enfants
qu'importe la grandeur de vos qualités
si elles nous permettent pas de remplir
cette condition
votre ligne et s'éteindra
je te promets de tenue toute ma vie
bella ciao surveys il a mis aussi
fondamentaux que bien
alors oui voiture les 10 communes idées
qui sont un groupe paléogène de cet
acier dactyle endémique d'europe 1 sont
polis filet ticket
amendement jeunes qui voulaient faire un
tour comme apple
tu vois moi je crois que l'homme de
s'élever de sa condition animale et
devenir un véritable pacifiste régler
ses problèmes par la tolérance et en
l'occurrence il existe tout un tas de
façons pour gagner au jeu de la
sélection naturelle
le vainqueur est celui qui parvient à
survivre suffisamment longtemps ou à
séduire suffisamment de partenaires pour
transmettre ces gènes et à cette fin et
et tous les moyens sont justifiées mais
ne nous égarons demandons donc
maintenant aux éléphants si la nature
est bien faite chez les éléphants les
dents ne pousse pas de base en haut mais
de l'arrière vers l'avant ils perdent
ainsi des dents tout au long de leur
longue vie et celle ci se renouvelle
sans cesse depuis le pont de la mâchoire
poussant d'arrière en avant comme sur un
tapis roulant se renouvelant alain vie
aimer ya plus de dents là bas non et
pourquoi il ya plus de dents devrait y
avoir des dents non ben non il y en a
plus tout simplement parce que les
éléphants comme les mammifères dont ils
descendent ont un nombre limité de
molaires ils en ont 3 et c'est tout
comptez vous aussi vous n'avez que trois
mots l'air et alors qu'est ce qui se
passe si la plus de dents l'éléphant et
bien ils meurent de faim non mais
attends c'est horrible comment c'est
possible ça évolutive m'en parle en et
bien tout simplement parce que la
sélection naturelle ce n'est pas
seulement la survie du plus apte
c'est surtout une histoire de
reproduction arrivé à l'âge de la perte
de la dernière molères c'est à dire vers
60 ans les éléphants ont déjà eu plein
de petit éléphanteau à qui l'ont
transmis cette tare et ainsi elle se
perpétue de génération en génération
et oui s'il ne s'agissait que de
survivre alors nous serions tous
immortel
un autre exemple
regardons du côté des cétacés les
baleines et des dauphins ses monuments
de majesté véritable fuite est
l'adaptation en mode de vie aquatique et
c'est un oeil oui car contrairement aux
vrais poissons les cétacés eux n'ont pas
de branchies et ils sont obligés de
remonter à la surface pour respirer
précisément là où les attendent les
baleiniers et oui car en réalité les
cétacés ne sont pas des poissons mais
sont des descendants de mammifères
autrefois terrestre qui devait
ressembler à ça qu il cherchait des
baleines de ses ancêtres
ils ont hérité la capacité de donner
naissance à des bébés pleinement former
et de les allaiter
mais ils ont aussi hérité la présence de
poumons qui relié à l'heure et vendent
leur permet de respirer à l'air libre
uniquement arriver à ce niveau là il n'y
a plus de doute possible soit la nature
est très cruel ou un humour
particulièrement noire soit il faut bien
admettre que ces imperfections sur ce
que stephen jay gould appelait des
poteries collage de l'évolution un
dernier exemple pour être sûr allez
c'est parti
regardons du côté de l'homme et de la
femme oui si tu veux et de la femme
bah espèce humaine ça de la mieux
informée
bon on peut y aller maintenant ça va
l'espèce humaine n à s'autoproclamer
sommet de l'évolution
et pourtant elle ne fait pas exception
prenez le mal du siècle le mal de dos
les maux de dos sont principalement dû
au fait que notre colonne vertébrale
n'est pas droite mais forment un ace
elle est affectée par deux courbure qui
sont à l'origine de maux tels que la
scoliose la sciatique et c'est pourquoi
ces courbure n'aurait-il pas été plus
simple d'avoir une colonne droite comme
un i qui aurait supporté notre poids tel
une colonne portant un frontispice au
lieu de ça nous poillion et pillon sur
notre propre poids finissant par nous
effondré sur nous mêmes
pourquoi ce s vertébrale une mauvaise
blague d'un créateur facétieux non
simplement nos descendants d'un ancêtre
de lure simiesque or les singes comme
les autres espèces vivant sur leurs
quatre pattes ont le dos droit à
l'horizontale rejouons un peu le film de
l'évolution pour faire un humain il faut
mettre la colonne vertébrale à la
verticale comme ceci oui tu as raison tu
es pire ne touche plus le seul
arrangeons ça avec une première courbure
de ta colère ça va mieux
tant mieux continuer tes yeux ne regarde
pas dans la bonne direction
maintenant que tu es bipèdes il faut
regarder devant toi arrangeant cela avec
une deuxième courbure de la colonne plus
haute cette fois ci et voilà désormais
notre singe ancestrale hypothétique a
évolué et est devenu bipèdes avec toutes
les contorsions de la colonne que cela
implique
et c'est certainement ce qui est arrivé
à nos propres ancêtres expliquant
pourquoi nous sommes ainsi affublé d'une
colonne ans s est pas en commun ce qui
concerne les cétacés et les éléphants
notre anatomie n'est pas dépourvu
d'imperfections et leur présence
s'explique très bien par le fait que les
espèces évoluent les unes à partir des
autres et que certaines se traîne de
véritables casseroles évolutive hérité
de leurs ancêtres ses casseroles sont la
preuve que ces espèces ne furent pas
toujours ce qu'elles sont ce stock
options c'est terminé merci de l'avoir
suivi nous espérons vous avoir
convaincus que la nature n'est pas si
bien fait et que les imperfections sont
les cicatrices de l'histoire évolutive
des espèces
pour en savoir plus à ce sujet nous vous
recommandons la lecture de l'excellent
pouce du panda 2 stephen jay gould
merci à tous
pas
qui dit nombril du cordon ombilical nom
et qui dit cordon ombilical dit des tas
de merde [ __ ] cordon ombilical un
goujat tamer quoi le matin au réveil
c'est toujours la même question est ce
que je me lève ou non cette question si
je me la pose c'est que je suis un
hominidé la bonne recette pour faire un
brin en espèces ce que le fait d'avoir
un ballon comme par exemple
tyrannosaurus au bon on l'appelle re de
genre il faut aussi un nom de famille
comme un nombre d'espèces qui sera rex
au zapping